so speaking of football um dude what a
weekend of football unbelievable
unbelievable
some of the best games i've seen in
years
yeah
i mean that game i mean the kansas city
game uh was
unreal i mean my data text means like
best game i've ever seen
it might like it's gonna go down as one
of the top 10 games of all time without
a doubt
i mean if that was a if that was a
division championship game like it would
be top five
um
but those dudes came flat out of play oh
i mean how old's josh allen
this is like his third year maybe fourth
year i mean the new guard is coming joe
burrow josh josh allen
patrick um herbert yeah no i mean some
of these other rookies might pop up i
mean there's some dudes that can just
play football there's no defense and i'm
not sure but with patrick and and josh
like they move around so well
i mean josh is like his own running he's
like a running back as well he's a
monster he's huge
so you either run the ball with them or
you play zone and then he's going to
throw the ball but if you blitz him and
you don't get home he's just going to
make bigger plays and patrick's the same
and they got really good coaches i feel
like you know those
they got
great head coaches they've got good
offensive coordinators they've got
talent i think they've done a good job
of getting talent around josh over the
years if they get them one more stud um
they're gonna be right there
in racing there's kind of like a the
question of car or driver
yeah so
um what's the in in sort of football
language what's the difference between
like team and coach how big of a role
like if you if you have a great team and
a shitty coach
versus a great coach in an average team
i mean because i don't feel like you
know there's nobody in the nfl that's
like that's anything other than average
at the worst
yeah true
sure kind of like racing it's not like
you have some terrible driver with uh
like everybody can do it so we're
working with like average
to great so what's more important do you
think
coach or do you think the team you know
for me as a quarterback like the
offensive coordinator was vital to me i
thought
like you know that's
calling plays to me is like an art form
like you know you've got to get in the
flow you've got to kind of guess what
they're going to play
um you know you can't just look at your
sheet and be like all right let's just
go with this this and this and see what
happens like there's a
there's a there's a delicacy there that
like a finesse so is it the offensive
coordinator that's calling more of the
calls than the coach
is he telling the coach what to put what
to run
like most teams head coach
very few teams head coach actually call
the place you know kyle shanahan does
mcveigh does
read you know reed does for kc that just
goes through a different guy
but most head coaches have a defensive
coordinator and an offensive coordinator
that will call the player separately
and the head coach will hear him but he
doesn't have any say in what's being
called
so like that for me that offensive
coordinator was i mean he made it break
me
and the team
so you know if he called if he calls you
know a shitty play then you know
you
maybe maybe sometimes you can get out of
it sometimes you have to run it and you
just you have to take the loss so
but with that being said i'm sure it's
like this in race car driving like
there's
so many i guess that would be like that
would be the car for you
yeah so like there's probably
like there's probably there's only a
handful of
amazing offensive coordinators in nfl
which having
race cars there's probably only a
handful of you know amazing cars out
there
yeah yeah yeah i could probably
interject and add like we could probably
add a third element perhaps of like crew
chief or something like that but
but you know so okay so
that would be like your gm
yeah
like he would be one of drafting the
players and like he's like your third
element like if he sucks too
you're not gonna get any good players so
how far out is a gm thinking like does a
gm go into the draft every year and
think this year
or are they almost always playing the
long-term chess game
they they do both they have to do both
and and they have to do like free agents
and the current team so
you know most of the time like you're
gonna have there there's gonna be a try
tryout like every monday or tuesday of
new guys that they kind of are just
bringing in and they'll work them out
you know there's a practice squad guys
that will kind of trade in and out
there's the bottom like
bottom five percent of the roster about
three per stride of the roster is kind
of always evolving
oh what a shitty position to be in to be
honest
i mean like where you live and
i felt bad for someone you know as you
get older like you feel bad for those
guys like you get you get a kid in and
you know he's 25 he's married and like
this is like his ninth team he's you
know
pressing his butt to make the team it's
just like
it's a it's a brutal business
hmm yeah yeah uh okay what about within
the team as far as like what's the most
important within the team from your
perspective you've got
quarterback
wide receivers like running backs tight
end
what's the what's the what's the rank of
like if you're to build your team you
start with and go down quarterback
you know i mean if you look at
you know the four teams in like they got
they have dudes that can
they can play football
um and consistently like over time like
you have to have a quarterback that can
play
i think after that if you if you have
your quarterback um
you got to get your offensive line
yeah
you know you've got to you got to be
able to block you've got to be able to
protect these guys i mean these guys all
these guys are getting a little bit more
um mobile they can move around like the
days of
you know a damn arena or you know even a
joe montana or a tom brady just sitting
in the pocket
yeah
you know being almost statue like it's
kind of it's kind of it's not happening
anymore it's going away so that helps
because of the defense is that because
the defenses are evolving well i think
it's because of high school and college
they're running different systems you
know they're
they're that that that game has changed
so these guys are a lot more athletic
than they used to be
yeah so i think after that you guys
i think a lot of nfl starts up front
d-line and o-line is is if you got if
you can rush the passer
and protect the or protect the pastor
like you're gonna be
you're gonna be right there you need
like one at every level on defense so
you need a defensive lineman you need a
badass linebacker and then maybe a
corner or a safety and then you can fill
in your gaps
do you like watching football now that
you're done
you know i didn't like the first year i
was out like i was like
i mean i just wasn't interested in it
and i you know i didn't know what i was
going to do when i was done either so i
took a break didn't watch it and then as
the boys got a little bit older now
they're just flat out obsessed so okay
well who are their teams
tell me it's the bears that'll be
hilarious
um cam likes the bear i mean the problem
and that's another problem with i think
to today's kids is you know we have
direct tv so like we have that sunday
ticket package so like we play
all the games yeah they're on the
internet they know
every player
and so like
he was a san diego chargers fan because
he loved herbert and then last night
like he's screaming about kc
loves patrick mahomes i'm like bro like
you're turning into a band like a fan
like this is i mean he busted in the
room at six o'clock he was like you can
you say this morning he was like can you
believe that game because ben jackson
just watched the highlights at the end
and i was like i know it's a good one i
go so you uh kc fan he goes love patrick
i'm like you i don't know how i feel
about it but i mean i'm glad he enjoys
it but it's still
you know whenever i was growing up i
mean i grew up in soda indiana and you
know
all we had was the bears games
like that was your one game that you got
to watch and then you know i think that
you got monday night game and stuff but
like you didn't have the opportunity to
watch
nine games in one day i i didn't know
that about you so were you
stoked to play for the bears um yeah i
was excited
i was excited um because i grew up in
southern indiana and then all my
family's from northern indiana like uh
gary so basically chicago let's just
call chicago exactly so they were
everyone was excited you know we had a
bunch of people at every game so it was
fun
[Music]